[Music]
now Steve how are you great how are you
dad good
Lynch last time you played a pickup game
since I retired to a nap years ago I I
played one pickup game with Chris Mullin
at st. John's wait and only Molly could
get me to play basketball I haven't
played otherwise ever tired
is it not fun yeah I don't know I don't
know I love the game but I think just
after you know pushing myself for so
many years a shooting every day and and
you know pushing and playing and for so
long I just it just doesn't mean I gonna
play at the park or the gym just doesn't
seem as exciting for me so yeah I really
had the urge to play but didn't you use
to when you were in New York City you
would just show up at a random Park and
play pick-up basketball and the guys
there didn't realize who you were no not
really
well you never did that not really
I might have once or something but I
think it would have been totally not the
norm you know in the summer I would
train and obviously all summer but I
wouldn't go and play pick-up basketball
really no all right well maybe that my
sources are not good sources then cuz I
was I was told you'd like go to a
playground and then they'd play and they
didn't realize that it was Steve Nash
out there so never mind that question
will strike that from the record
we were we were wondering about Mike
D'Antoni's system and how it's helped
James Harden can you tell us as
basketball novices what dance what does
D'Antoni do for his point guard that
other coaches don't well I think he'd
trust them they give them a lot of
freedom to you know to get in get
downhill and get in the paint and make
plays for their team you know I think
Mike's a brilliant basketball mind and
obviously it's had an impact on the
whole league and I also think that
Houston he's done a great job you
surrounded harden loose in the
phenomenal years you know I think right
I understand
a reason Gordon some of these guys that
are having careers shaking the ball part
of that is as James and Mike system and
part of that is that these guys can
really shoot and together they stretch
the swath of the defense in such a
difficult position that I they're always
having to pick their poison and one of
them has the beneficiary it seems on on
every other possession so you know I
think it's a great fit for everybody and
I'm proud of Mike and happy forums he's
a great person and I think he's had an
impact when we but you know what times
his talked about and sometimes I think
because of what happened in New York in
LA kind of gets uh under credited for
what he's what he's done for the game
but don't you have to have that point
guard if you're gonna run his system it
has to start there and then it sort of
filters out after that certainly helps I
think you know I think you have a guy
who's capable of scoring and
facilitating keep the defense honest and
can make decisions and you know really
take apart the defense for deciding what
they're trying to take away or making
mistakes obviously that's a huge part of
the success of that system but I think
you know Mike's brilliance was that he
was able to recognize that that kind of
organized chaos or that freelance women
uh within a loose structure can be more
effective than than all the coaching and
over kind of thinking it and putting
players in a position where they're
constantly happening to do one of two
things that maybe you pre-determined I
think giving them the freedom to be and
react and use their skill levels
now as this paramount to that system
success he's Steve Nash two-time MVP
joining us Dan Patrick show where are
those trophies
I don't know I'm actually moving this
week and I'm guessing my dad has them
last tenant I knew where they were there
in my garage but they're not there now
so wait in a box they were in a yeah in
a box in a storage and the plastic nice
box oh okay a nurse star type of lock
what's your official title now ah dad
mostly most most of the time just dad
but I'm assuming your name with the
Warriors yeah I think it's player
development consultant which is the play
title the title you know basically you
know my role is is to be a resources for
the organization and particularly for
the coaches and players you know to be
able to be there whenever they need to
look at something today they think I can
have an impact on and and just you know
and that time comes and I think a lot of
times it just comes out of conversations
with evil with let the pill put the
players and you know I can find that I
can share maybe some my experience and
can have an impact but you know it's
pretty informal and I think for a
cricket reason and I'm at a part-time
job if you were playing now coming out
now how different would your game be
with how the game is played now you know
I don't know I think maybe I would have
been more aggressive to score you know I
think when I came into league it was
there still such a you know importance
placed on being a pure point guard or
being a playmaker a pass first point
guard and obviously that's been turned
on its head and I think the point guard
is has been an exploited and in a way
anymore they were coaches and people
realize you know it's just such an
advantage to have a player that can put
so much pressure on the defense and not
necessarily think past first so I still
think it's a place for a pass pass first
point guard but I think that you know a
the way the evolution of the Canes gone
and the way some of these guys are
scoring the ball I might have been more
aggressive to score but it's just in my
nature to think past her so I mean I
wouldn't have gone for my game but maybe
I would have come a little bit more
towards the senses but how do we
distinguish between Harden and Westbrook
for MVP if those are the two top
candidates but what would be the most
important factor for you
well I think people have been saying
recently in it and I guess it sure is
that it's it you know a lot of it
historically has come down to keen
success as well you know in the in the
you know within the context of how their
team is performs and so I think in that
definition you know harden has an
advantage because he's elevated just
team as can make this year you know and
then you look at Russell and you think
wow I mean this guy is having a
historical ethical season like you've
never seen and there's elevated his own
play and then you know you can look
around a league and think of LeBron I
think sometimes gets underrated because
there is impact in the game company /
that's his log for that team and and
Kawhi Leonard I think is underrated good
for them so yeah you know I said this
the other day I think that the MVP
voting and/or the debate it almost is
more about the voter and all of us
spectators and it does about the actual
players because it is such an objective
thing so there is no rule but there is
no real criteria this is kind of a
tradition and it almost you know it says
more about our preferences and biases
and it does about the actual players
because they're all having mvp-type
seasons and deserve to be in the
conversation and all the be deserving
winners there Shaq ever give you grief
about those MVPs doesn't he say those
are his MVPs that you have he said yeah
he the only time he's ever said that to
me was when I came on excitement TNT you
know he said they'd already brought it
up and so he he said I Steve knows that
I told Matt but that was the first time
you never kind of mention it to my face
and what you saying I mean I would like
all things as Shaq he kind of you know
he's he's the comedian I think as much
as anything so he just kind of laughed
and he was a lot of fun to play with had
us all you know in stitches half the
year so he's you know like the Shaq's
marching life he's like he's a he's
great to have his personality and the
game still even though they don't have
not on the floor you know Steve
those are my MVPs I'd like to have them
back
telescope Birdman working on that oh
yeah even when Shaq comes on he'll he'll
do the imitation of Shack to Shack damn
Patrick shut the hell up
tell us what you're doing with with
Allstate sounds like a great great
little clinic you yeah yeah it's awesome
the NABC yeah good works team they've
got ten college basketball players who
have just been unbelievable this year
and and in the past years of doing
things for the community and
volunteering their time some of these
guys you see some of the things they've
done but creative platforms to help
people in different causes really kind
of impact so we're all gonna get
together and Arizona be great to be back
there for me and we're gonna do a
Special Olympics Connick and just you
know spend some time with these kids and
kind of uh hopefully set an example for
other kids to be a part of their
communities and help make a difference
well it's great to touch base with you
good luck being a father and whatever
else are you do you want to be a coach
or GM you have any interest in doing it
no not really I really enjoy me and dad
and value and cannot be another get up
with these kids and take them up from
school and be their chauffeur an uber
driver and all that stuff so at this
point I'm I'm thrilled to do that and
just have a small role the Warriors that
keeps me in touch with the game would
you rather your kids played soccer or
basketball good question I mean I just I
just love I just wanted to be active I'd
love to play either frankly right now
it's right now I'm not so sure that's
gonna happen they're not playing either
one of them you can invite my six girls
he is playing them both but he's he's
lukewarm right now so I'm trying to be
that dad that uh that four seven locks
him in and in a gym for a few hours
you're not levar ball okay not not quite
I would say that's that's a certainty
thank you Steve good to talk to you and
have fun in in Phoenix
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience